[Music]
Joey yeah you got a second I think
there's something in the loading dock we
have to check out and pick up the front
says that it's a box for us I don't know
okay cool okay yeah it's been a while
since we've done an unboxing video so
yeah I know this way Michael I need that
script on my desk ASAP
it's kind of weird I've never really
been out here I've actually never been
in the loading dock to be in Tekken 7
[Music]
I guess we better on Vox
[Music]
you
[Music]
where do I start where do we even begin
I only do not know where
wait wait wait what what this Halloween
uh-oh looks like we I think we got to
slice it no you're big wow you're so
good with a razor blade dude I don't
know if you did anything right here
[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger blade
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait no gunshot cut that tape do the
honors oh oh good it's got wheels now we
can roll it nice and those there's two
of them
there's another one good weight would
get the top up I don't think that's
important Joey Joey
Johnny nice I guess we'll get a
screwdriver huh oh I guess this was
handy well I don't want to shred this
there we're gonna need a little bit more
powerful 20s I'll be right back it's not
on yet practicing what's that one combos
like 2 1 3 3 2 sure yeah yeah we're high
fives I was a low five
okay well redo the second
people in the office are gonna lose it
see the handle right wait hold on Lu you
get how heavy is this exact something's
that matter watch your feet it's fine
all right should we will this stuff you
couldn't wheel this one that's right
that's right it's a little dusty but
we'll get a little baby wipe action on
this
that was our unboxing video it was a
little unorthodox you could say but
we're not done yet this Friday we have a
live stream Joey yep we'll have some
people from bandai namco coming in
showing us the ropes including a pro
player so he's bound to kick our ass but
stay tuned Friday
make sure to subscribe yeah that's it
for now thanks guys for watching
take care
you
[Music]